[Musica]
bene ad un certo punto ho pensato di
andare via di andare via da quella terra
una terra che fino a poche decennio fa
era anche una terra bella e fertile e
poi negli ultimi anni è diventata una
terra contaminata avvelenata
i roghi i fuochi la camorra il degrado
ambientale ed umano più profondo
però io quando sono andata via avevo già
in testa un modello di scuola a cui
volevo tendere un modello di scuola
lontano dalle emergenze e soprattutto
lontano dal contro volevo costruire
costruire qualcosa volevo volevo il
pearl e non il contro e quindi quando mi
sono trasferita nel cilento che una
bella terra una terra ancora in parte
incontaminata l'immensa bellezza tra
mare e montagna
la prima scuola che mi ha accolto una
piccolissima piccolissimo istituto
comprensivo in un paesino del cilento
poi ne ho cambiato più di uno perché
insomma tra problematiche varie sotto
dimensionamenti ridimensionamenti ma
anche qualche conflitto con gli
amministratori locali che per la verità
non mi amano molto questo cercherò di
capirlo
più avanti noi non ci sono ancora
riuscita
io ho cominciato dalle piccole cose
io mi portavo dietro solo questo sogno
il sogno di realizzare una scuola con
questi con questi miei ideali e mi
portavo i miei occhi gli occhi che
avevano visto cosa succede alla terra
quando non si interviene perché io sono
sicura che se nella mia terra avessimo
avuto delle scuole attente e avessero
insegnato agli alunni l'impegno
a difenderla la propria terra forse noi
in terra dei fuochi non avremmo fatto
quella fine
bene il cilento appartiene alla campania
e l'estrema zona a sud della campania e
quindi io avevo questa questa idea di
costruire questo modello che tenesse
presente queste istanze i miei amici i
miei familiari mi dicevano guarda che
non è possibile non potrai farlo perché
tu non andrai a gestire una scuola
privata tu andrai a gestire una scuola
dello stato dove ci sono delle normative
molto stringenti e tu dovrai rispettarle
per cui tutto quello che tu vuoi
realizzare non ti sarà possibile non si
può fare
beh io poi sono un po capatosta insomma
perché insomma io volevo a tutti i costi
mettere in connessione
stasera si è utilizzata molto la parola
simbiosi le mie due grandi passioni che
sono la didattica e la terra la natura e
gli apprendimenti e quindi io quando
sono arrivato in questa prima piccola
scuola ho cominciato subito perché io
non ho in questi anni realizzato tutti
insieme abbiamo cominciato un po per
volta piccolissimi cambiamenti piccole
buone pratiche ambientali perché il
cambiamento insomma in una scuola e
è molto lento credo che sia uno dei
luoghi più restii al cambiamento
la scuola eppure è successo qualcosa di
incredibile perché poi in questi anni ne
abbiamo fatte tante di cose dal
compostaggio domestico agli orti ai
frutteti all'orchestra tutta realizzata
con con rifiuti con materiale di scarto
è successo qualcosa di incredibile
tutto mi veniva incontro tutto si
realizzava perché io qualsiasi cosa io
ipotizzarsi bene ora è venuto il momento
di fare questo faremo questo le persone
ci credevano
tutto mi veniva incontro come se stasera
la prima volta che lo utilizzo questo
termine pensandoci riflettendoci
permettetemelo è avvenuto io non lo so
perché per quale motivo qualcosa di
miracoloso
ecco l'ho detto il termine difficile
perché c'era qualcosa che permetteva me
e alla mia squadra perché poi ho sempre
avuto una squadra intorno che io
realizzassi quel quel progetto quel
modello e c'era questo slogan cambiare
l'educazione per cambiare il mondo non
l'ho inventato io che mi ha un po
illuminato non mi ha un po aperto la
strada che abbiamo cominciato a
realizzare delle piccole cose io vi farò
solo qualche esempio
abbiamo cominciato con l'educazione
alimentare perché per me questa terra il
cilento ma anche tutto il sud italia che
al primo posto per l'obesità infantile
per me
non meritavano questi bambini questi
miei alunni di cui io mi prendevo cura
di snack e il cibo spazzatura che
l'industria alimentare destina alloro e
quindi abbiamo cominciato a fare tanta
educazione alimentare
ad un certo punto i bambini sono sono
esseri intelligentissimi hanno
cominciato a rifiutarlo tutto quello che
era a loro destinato e noi abbiamo
proposto l'eco merenda che non è niente
di eccezionale e il niente di
rivoluzionario è una cosa semplicissima
accessibile a tutti e una buona fetta di
pane olio il pane e olio e ricominciare
da queste cose così semplici così solo
che il pane quello buono e quello fatto
con le farine locali e non è quello
imbustato quello è la buona pagnotta di
pane tagliata a fette e l'olio e quello
cilentano e quello extravergine prodotto
dalle famiglie che poi piano piano i
frantoi produttori le famiglie insomma
ce lo regalano perle come rende dei
nostri bambini poi piano piano le come
renda si è arricchita anche di altre
versioni con il pane e marmellata con la
frutta fresca la frutta secca i fichi
secchi del cilento sono famosi in tutto
il mondo e poi invece mi ritrovavo i
miei bambini che mangiavano le porcherie
insomma del dl del mondo dell'industria
alimentare
io ho questa sta capa insomma che mimì
mi obbliga alla coerenza
insomma io poi sono anche figlia di
contadini e e quindi sarà anche per
questo che dopo qualche mese
che lavoravo in questa scuola in cui
parlavo di terra e didattica
mi hanno appioppato una definizione che
è la preside per la terra una
definizione che mi ha riempito
d'orgoglio perché il termine terra poi
rafforzato e ripetuto due volte
insomma mi piace tanto mi piace
moltissimo per cui non l'ho mai ritenuto
un insulto e nemmeno una denigrazione e
il vero salto di qualità è avvenuto
quando abbiamo cominciato a piantare gli
alberi per fortuna le scuole di questa
questa zona d'italia hanno tutti un
grandissimo spazio fu spazi abbandonati
o materiali di risulta anche da 20 anni
da 30 anni abbandonati noi li abbiamo
ripuliti noi noi significa io i docenti
gli alunni i collaboratori scolastici
i genitori i nonni abbiamo ripulito
tantissimi apprezzamenti di terra e
abbiamo piantato tanti alberi da frutta
frutta nelle scuole la conoscete e non è
quella non è quella del ministero quella
vera perché i bambini si prendono cura
degli alberi ne seguono lo sviluppo
imparano proprio a seguirli nella loro
crescita a documentarla monitoraggi e
poi mangiano raccolgono e mangiano e
consumano i frutti si raccolgono da
questi alberi così come gli orti solo
sugli orti mi soffermerò poco perché
tutti ormai sanno quanto e valide
quant'è importante l'attività di avere
un orto a scuola è fondamentale si apre
a mille
distanze differenti e ci si può lavorare
a 360 gradi
lo sanno tutti cene in italia tantissimi
a me preme ricordare un particolare che
la dieta mediterranea è nata proprio nel
cilento ed è uno degli elementi una
delle caratteristiche della dieta
mediterranea non è solo gli ingredienti
buoni e sani ma è proprio la
convivialità la condivisione per cui la
[Musica]
cresta questo aspetto della convivialità
e della condivisione è stato un po il
filo rosso intorno poi intorno a cui
costruire tutte le altre attività
ce ne sono tantissimi di laboratori
attivati in questi anni di riciclo di
recupero di ricostruzione di tradizione
di innovazione senza mai rinunciare alla
tecnologia ma ce ne sta uno che è la
raccolta dell'olio esausto che veniva
come nelle migliori tradizioni da
questionari fatti a scola buttato nel
lavandino insomma con i questionari
fatti con i bambini
ebbene noi abbiamo cominciato insomma
raccontare a spiegare con i biologi
marini insomma cosa accade al nostro
mare
quando ci finisce dentro noi abbiamo uno
dei mari più spettacolari l'italiano nel
cilento
quando ci finisce dentro questa massa
che attraversa insomma anche i
depuratori mal funzionanti altre storie
e come muore la vita e quindi i bambini
che sono delle persone serie
hanno detto no noi l'olio fritto l'olio
alimentare nel lavandino
ma ce lo mettiamo più che abbiamo
cominciato a raccoglierlo poi con
antiche sarebbe troppo lungo di abbiamo
recuperato delle antiche ricette locali
con le norme con i nonni che abbiamo
cominciato
e sapone noi oggi produciamo migliaia di
saponette che non solo utilizziamo noi
poi si è arricchito il progetto perché
le facciamo adesso anche con le essenze
quel riconoscimento delle erbe
selvatiche con altri laboratori dove i
bambini vanno ad individuare i ragazzi
vanno ad individuare le erbe le assenze
queste saponette le doniamo perché non
si può dire vendere prima cosa vietata e
con il ricavato sosteniamo proprio
quelle famiglie che hanno più bisogno
dei progetti di solidarietà anche
lontani quindi un esempio vero dicono
l'economia circolare e solidarietà a
costo zero e senza alcun alcuna
difficoltà le difficoltà sono quelle di
tipo di tipo normativo insomma de si può
fare non si può fare in una scuola che
insomma io sono riuscita un po ad
evitare ecco c'è ancora un altro
elemento importante quando abbiamo
proposto queste attività soprattutto il
pane olio
i bambini sono stati felicissimi ai
bambini è piaciuto tantissimo io all
istituto comprensivo dai 3 ai 14 anni
tutti hanno amato l'eco merenda beh chi
non la ama e ha delle perplessità e
delle difficoltà il mondo adulto il
mondo adulto che a cui piace meno io
all'inizio non capivo
poi ho capito che quando tu proponi a
una società una comunità una fetta di
pane olio questa agita immediatamente
dei fantasmi interiori
la gente viene riportata velocemente
indietro ad un passato ancora troppo
vicino in cui il pane olio insomma
rimanda a una
una miseria a una privazione a una
mancanza e seri fortunato insomma veri
una fetta di pane olio a cui attingere
quindi la sfida grande che è toccata a
me e ai miei docenti è stata quella di
riposizionare nella contemporaneità e
quindi nel presente ma soprattutto nel
futuro il pane olio l'educazione alla
ruralità e la consapevolezza
dell'appartenenza ad una terra che ti
indica quali sono i cibi sani i cinque
buoni che non sono quelli diciamo di
cibo spazzatura
concludo con un ultimo progetto
bellissimo a cui sono molto affezionata
la realizzazione di un orchestra con
strumenti musicali interamente
realizzati con la spazzatura
io a volte mi a volte mi sento un po
figliano di quelle discariche di quella
spazzatura in cui negli ultimi anni ero
stata costretta a vivere a vedere per
cui per me insomma recuperare i rifiuti
e farli diventare musica era è stato
qualche cosa che mi ha molto molto
commossa ed emozionata soprattutto
quando la mia orchestra fatta di una
ventina di ragazzini ha cominciato ad
esibirsi in giro attivato tantissima
bellezza e questo è l'altro punto
portare la bellezza scuola coniugare
didattica e bellezza non solo didattiche
terra ma didattiche bellezza perché io
le ho viste tante di scuse e la bellezza
spesso non ci sono dei non luoghi
molto tristi per me invece è una grande
soddisfazione aver realizzato un luogo
un luogo di poesia di bellezza di cura e
attenzione dove le persone stanno
insieme
dove c'è la relazione c'è l'affettività
ci sono le emozioni bene
tutto questo è stato realizzato nella
scuola pubblica nella scuola dello stato
italiano
quella della costituzione e dei diritti
io dico sempre ai miei amici miei
familiari ea tanti altri soprattutto a
quelli che mi hanno messo il bastone tra
le ruote mi hanno hanno provato anche a
farmi male in questi anni che non è vero
che non si poteva fare si può fare si
può fare è stato possibile quindi io
invito sempre tutti a rivederla la
categoria dell'impossibile
grazie
[Applauso]